why does this resonate with kids more
than it does to people who are older
I I think in some sense it's just
because they live longer they have more
likelihood of experiencing the really
bad impacts of of climate change but
probably also because we're uh you know
when you're young certainly I had that
experience you just hear all these scary
stories and you think oh my God the
world is going to end uh if you're a
little older you've heard a lot of other
scary stories I mean if you think back
to the first environment Summit in the
in the UN in 1972 in Stockholm uh the
head of that environment uh conference
told the world we have just 10 years
left in 1972. so you know we constantly
hear this and you know there's always
the next thing around that's going to
destroy us all and once you've heard a
few of them maybe you've become a little
more skeptical about the next one and
you should